well this school year has been a
challenge for students for parents for
teachers
most of clark county school district is
distance learning of course
well last night ccsd talked about how to
start moving forward
hector mejia live this morning from
district headquarters with some of the
outcomes from that meeting last night
hector
here john well in short students will
not be going to a physical classroom
just yet the school district here says
they're trying to find the perfect
balance to do it safely
and right now they are not ready to make
a decision so discussions
are still flowing between the school
district and local health experts
in last night's regular meeting the
southern nevada health district warned
that the risk of transmission in schools
is still high
a reason for the district to keep the
schools closed
some including trustee linda young
suggested giving schools
the option to make their own choices
based on needs
others referred to a spike in crisis
response team referrals
a big concern mentioned during a
presentation last night
and here's part of the conversation we
heard about what to do next
we keep putting band-aids on something
we know
is not healthy for our children but we
refuse to have the conversation about
what is the risk versus what we know is
happening
las vegas has a lot of risk not just
being an urban
city but being a the capital of tourism
and being a place that if not done
correctly
we could re-spread the virus across the
country
struggles with mental health were
another issue highlighted last night
including a lack of school psychologists
which sits at a ratio of about only one
psychologist for every 1800 students the
national average sits
at a ratio of roughly one to 700 and
some trustees acknowledge that these
decisions
are weighing heavy on them no matter
what they decide will have a huge impact
on a lot of families here
in our valley reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now